poi risponde fare risolvi il cubo di
rubik in diretta non lo faceva secoli
però vabbè ci prova cercherò di fare la
faccia da idiota dall'inizio alla fine
per renderlo più difficile ancora mi
sento piena mascella ok nella city
ragazzi proprio di questo colore io sono
fa vigenti come dj oggi siamo sul mio
blog a chi è bello quando indico sta
aprendo perché è un secolo e non faccio
perché ogni volta che faccio un cazzo di
blog passano anni fa tenuti un credeva
hanno fatto in coppia con garibaldi
forse non mi ricordo ragazzi cosa sente
di ricominciare colla parata della
settimana elaborata la settima ragazza è
questa qui che è fatta da non lo so da
chi è fatta pro cribbio non dormo più io
lo vorrei di ragazzi però quando fu fan
art c assicuratevi che io possa poi
dormire perché questo coso qui c'è non è
che sia proprio sexy ma non importa
purché ragazzino di partire con le news
perché devo dirmi un macello di cosa ma
che in tre settimane ha curato tanta di
quella roba da dire che lasciamo perdere
comunque la scaletta che mi ero segnato
tre settimane fa perché mi insegno le
news avevo scritto che volevo
ringraziarvi per gli 800mila iscritti
che sono un traguardo pazzesco ragazzi
ma nel mentre che aspettavo così se noi
ragazzi siamo dati 850 mila iscritti
quindi sticazzi a dire ragazzi vi
ringrazio di cuore una cosa pazzesca
bene cosa che vi volevo di ragazzi che
più o meno è una settimana che penso ne
siete accorti che invece di fare un
video al giorno ne sto facendo circa uno
ogni due perché è praticamente sono nel
periodo finale degli esami e quindi pro
ragazzi siamo praticamente alla fine dal
10 luglio in poi ve lo dico già la data
da 10 luglio e poi ragazzi inizierà a
fare video ogni giorno perché ho premuto
finito 15 hanno vinto a bomba in una
maniera incredibile
avevo già detto un po i ragazzi
resistete quest'ultima settimana e poi
ci siano state tranquilli ma se io devo
dire ragazze che finito auto ascom
finito di pop due mesi fa va bene 2
miliardi di serie horror da iniziare non
so quale scegliere perché mi piace
all'imbarazzo ma poi vedremo inoltre
agazzi ci sono due horror spettacolari
che voglio fare quando usciranno che
sono
è il wi fi in alien isole shaun che
probabilmente ragazzi non ci riuscirò
vivo ad asti gameplay però quando
usciranno li farò di sicuro perché come
sempre sono masochista e infine ragazzi
prima di passare allo scatto di pacchi
malware viene così nato e credo vi
interessi un pochettino siccome non ho
potuto fare blog
ultimamente i partigiani si sono
accumulati dato che me lo chiedete tutti
sempre di far vedere quanto i pacchi ciò
da scartare venivano a prendere giusto
per farvi vedere passa cazzo cazzo nel
prossimo programma si ho deciso di fare
una puntata diciamo speciali cercherò di
aprire tutti quanti partigiana un blog
dedicato soltanto ai pacchi lee isley
aprirò tutti quanti ragazzi aprirle tre
che sono leggermente grossi però prima
di partire c'è una cosa troppo bella
mano già scritto ho aspettato donare
alle poste e spero che ti piaccia amico
mi hai tutta la mia [ __ ] stima
progetti dico che ci metto due ora
scartarlo io quindi siamo pari per caso
mi dice che ci metto anche di più di due
ore quindi non siamo fuori un cazzo
proprio non importa se mi piace o
fattore ghiaccio fatte al primo colpo e
la è la prima cosa che ho trovato è
ragazzi io io non so non so qual è il
senso di tutto questo ma so che da
adesso in avanti alla mia vita ha un
senso non succede niente passato il
peggio tranquilli adesso staremo sempre
insieme sarai sempre protetta sempre
sempre sempre sempre sempre non volete i
ragazzi ho trovato un mare di caramelle
è una è una cannuccia
non so perché è un omino coi baffoni
teche tipo a a un taglio di capelli
molto ma molto più rinato del mio poi
una paperella è un dente enorme vabbè ma
se tipo messaggio in codice del tipo che
se mi mangio le caramelle mi cascano i
denti non lo so vorrei fini ragazzi mi
butto su quello grosso perché mi sembra
roba esageratamente grande ma sento bear
grylls come se stessi sognando una
lettera e dovremmo esserci il reato che
per persone tutto tutti i caldissimi
cioè che mario con federica pellegrini
ed ecco che cosa fa quando non nuota
giocato un kit mario non si sa come ma
la partita di giornali che trovo qui
dentro mi lascia sempre
senza parole ragazzina cd dei simpson
per playstation 2
porca [ __ ] che figo ma ecc non c'è
niente dentro mi state prendendo per il
culo però si sia perso qua dentro perché
non è così
c'è un'altra scatola ok c'è uno svendere
in miniatura che è parecchio figlio devo
dire attenzione perché c'è anche richard
gere ragazzi facciamo la collezione
completa è fiera o ma cos'è questo sono
ecco c'è una mia foto mezzo poster
dell'attacco dei giganti chiunque abbia
mandato questo pacco io ti amo ricorda
tottenham ostile ragazzi che è troppo
bella no cosa non mi viene da presa
neanche perché troppo [ __ ]
ecco mi mancava io no bellissima per
questo questo è geniale con l'accoppiata
slann da sono meravigliosi due fan art
spettacolari tra l'altro questa questa è
venuta benissimo anche questa però
questa questa mi piace perché c'è stick
che un filo incassi vi amo questo questo
lo sapete se siete d'accordo con lui
direi di passare al fa vi risponde la
prima domanda ragazza arriva da lilia
liliane e sei vivo e che serie tv allora
si segue al seguivo perché adesso con
gli esami non ce la faccio che fanno un
cazzo
seguivo breaking bad poi è toccato a
metà perché non ce la facevo più a
seguirlo perché c'è troppo da fare per
riprenderlo di sicuro ma tanto mano già
spoilerato mezzo mondo quindi lasciamo
perdere poi anche the walking dead
parecchio voleva vedermi anche lost che
avevo seguivo quando ero più piccolo
però non ci capisce un cazzo
ovviamente adesso ci capirai ancora di
meno però non lo so ci ha avuto sempre
sta cosa che dovevo chiedermelo
dall'inizio quindi prima o poi devo
farlo assolutamente risponde fatti
scrivi brano brano su google produttore
traduce in coreano e senti che dice bell
affare perché avete farmi fare le cose
tipo su google traduttore ancora non
l'ho capito ma vabbè
cosa devo cliccando cliccare sul car sul
cane ama qualcuno sempre piacere che
google traduttore sempre sempre dalla
mia parte angelo della serie fabris
quando il quale la tua saga preferita
più o meno allora la primissima credo
che sia reporter perché quando ero
piccolo mi guarda anche ad essa anzi
stamattina l'ho visto tra l'altro nome
non importa i libri ho letto soltanto i
primi quattro i film li ho visti e
continua rivederli anche a 90 anni
probabilmente sono lì a rivedermi harry
potter così risponde fuochi puoi fare un
buon tron nella realtà squali show del
foglio legge
[Musica]
corrisponde famiglia mai capitato che
mentre giocavi ti sei accorto alla fine
che non avevi registrato
se sì qual è stata la tua reazione mi è
capitato più volte anzi di video che ho
dovuto rifare dopo perché dopo che che
mi cosmi non so parlare dopo che mi sono
accorto che che non avevo registrato ho
dovuto anche registrare il nuovo non è
che poi lasciato parla del togo benin
mangia un gelato non ho avuto anche di
registrare tutto quindi si no
mi ricordo che cosa ho detto
precisamente però tipo mi colore giorno
dopo non avevo più la scrivania
veramente perché ci hanno tirato la tess
non lo so vabbè comunque la cosa
ragazzine che oggi può bastare anche
perché ciò la camera un po da mettere a
posto nel prossimo però che come ho già
detto ragazzi cercherò di aprire più poi
chi possibile perché non ce la faccio
più a camminare in casa praticamente a
dire che possono credere che i ragazzi
quindi se il vino è piaciuto come sai
cosa tuo commento mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook e una livida tratta
nella descrizione tre senatori city
scrive tipi di cibi di euro prossimo
video per ragazzi